I think we're at something of an
inflection point in management education
I think the events of 2008 have caused
us to really look deeply at what we're
doing in management education
fortunately here at the GSB we were a
little ahead of the curve we instituted
a new curriculum in 2007 which was very
innovative and which is helping us to
deal with the kinds of issues that I
think recent events have have brought to
center stage and management education
principled leaders need to think not
just about the impact of their actions
on their own firm and in particular not
just on their own shareholders but the
impacts of those actions on society more
broadly the world that leaders managing
has become increasingly complex over
time whether it's issues of
globalization or sustainability or the
need to innovate there's lots of
complexity that surrounds the day-to-day
life of any leading executive and the
the managers and leaders who do best are
those who are able to really understand
the complexity in which there managing
for example I think the people who
manage best through the financial crisis
with those who understood not just the
problems that their own companies were
facing but understood the entire context
in which they were managed in which they
were managing the problems in the debt
markets and so on and so we need to
educate students who are critical
analytical thinkers students who can
really dig deeply beyond their immediate
domain into the broader context in which
they manage we're really have an
extraordinary opportunity here at the
GSB with really unsurpassed student
talent coming in to give them these
tools and this inside and to launch them
from that into a life of meaning and
impact